hey guys this is a part of the DVD
little axe tried to say throw in talking
about the origins of the characters
there on the site that kind of glasses
comm so here we go
nostalgic rigs very much based on that
time I was going through I think
everybody goes through it when they
become really obsessed with what they
grew up with just the whole nostalgia
factor and I just tried to go for it
maybe college perhaps and I became
obsessed with finding everything that I
grew up with like everything I saw when
I was a kid and watching it I sort of
realized that a lot of stuff wasn't as
good as I remember it effect is usually
very bad so something I found out if I
know a lot of people really liked
talking about that they liked
reminiscing and remembering what they
grew up with and now there's a huge
market for it even there you go there's
a ton teachers advertising that you know
just things from the nostalgia gauge and
stuff like that so at the time I wanted
to see if I was still funny like
actually me you know and not my five
second movies and my editing I wanted to
see if I was actually funny so I came up
with this character that was betrayed by
his childhood the entry felt really
pissed off that his childhood wasn't as
good as he remembered it and gets really
angry at it and annoyed and obviously
was the character you see and people
really got attached to it and they liked
his outbursts and stuff like that so
that's about it
my number-one influence is discuss some
weird it's actually Daffy Duck which is
probably my number one influence rat
anything he's like my favorite comedian
even though he's not real
but that's pretty much where I get a lot
of material from and I think there's a
lot of him in disguise your critic
there's a lot of other people there's a
lot of Lewis Black Stephen Colbert the
little Bill Murray and stuff just pretty
much everybody I liked growing up is in
that character and there's a little bit
of me in there also particularly when I
do the serious stuff like some of the
top 11 lists but that's mainly who is
centered around the idea behind the
costume was that it be someone who
wanted to start looking professional but
then sort of got lazy halfway through
and gave up so I always liked the idea
of wearing a suit code and you know a
tie but I don't like wearing nice shirts
then I'm like wearing hat so I just sort
of threw that all together it's about
basic as it gets
the bum is centered off of a really dumb
voice I did in the Cloverfield review
where I was imitating the movie and I
just really loved doing that voice I
want to find a character to somehow keep
doing that voice and I didn't know what
the character was or what he do but I
didn't care I just wanted to keep doing
that voice because it was so easy it was
so much fun to do so the only very good
thing of is who would talk like that is
some sort of insane bomb so pretty much
I was trying to think how do I make this
a continuing series I know nostalgia
critic only did older films and shows so
why don't I have a character that does
current ones probably the biggest
influence without me even knowing it is
Bill Murray from Caddyshack that's
pretty much that voice in terms of a
character I I like characters that
really into their own world are very
confident of their own world but are
very happy there as well
I think characters like um like the calf
a red dwarf or Edie from Cowboy Bebop a
lot of sci-fi comedies might think about
but yeah I think those kind of
characters I really enjoy watching and
so I also enjoy playing so I think
that's about if it influences
the costume store came from beaches
looking through my closet seeing what I
could find and that's very much what I
found an old bears hat a trench coat
that used to be my grandfather's that I
think the blue jacket under it is also
his and the wig I think I found in a
with some of my Halloween stuff and yeah
I pretty much just everything hastily
thrown together
ask that guy came from Mike Mashhad he's
the guy who runs channel awesome pretty
much a guy in charge he runs the website
as well and when we were really giving
the started he gave me a call and pretty
much just said
ESCA ninjas really popular do something
like that click that's about it that's a
very rebate version but essentially
that's about it so I was trying to think
well ok ask that guy with the glasses
what would that be and I liked the idea
of making it interactive and having
people submit their questions but I
didn't know what the joke would be in
answering them
so for summaries the first thing came to
my mind is this very sophisticated
looking person with a pipe he has a robe
some sort of red ascot or something like
that
and the joke would always be that he
would get everything wrong not just
wrong phenomenally wrong like
unbelievably wrong
and from that sponsor this horrible
hate-filled
racist psychotic self-centered sexist
bigoted just pure ball of hate that's
dressed up to look very sophisticated so
you would believe him
I'm sure that someone I can't really
think though perhaps uh maybe John
Cleese somewhere there's some sort of
sophisticated British person talking
really silly and really stupid but
sounding very sophisticated so that you
don't notice that's about it I can think
of
the robe is actually bar goes and I've
yet to give it back pretty much held on
to it this whole time I actually sort of
feel bad now but yeah I don't think he's
ever gonna get back either after we're
done filming probably auction it off and
he'll never see it again so the red
asked god I I think I took an old red
shirt it just cut it up it's not even a
real scarf or whatever the fire but just
got as stores about those basic as you
can get again
Dominic is very interesting cuz that's
the first character I've done where he's
not the center of attention he's not the
joke
he's the straight guy and what he's
talking about the funny part so I was
trying to think of someone that was very
laid-back just very easygoing but
certainly looks like he's heard his his
bunch of stories there
so yeah that's it's about it sort of a
if there's nothing much funny about him
so can't talk too much about him I
forget his name but it's that guy from
snatch and and the the transporter
teleport or whatever that British guy on
a too lazy to look up his name but you
know who I'm talking about everyone says
I sound like him so it's it's that guy
it's nobody else it's pretty much just a
direct rip of bad guys and me doing a
very poor version of him so that's about
it as you went through a few different
designs on the look of him it was pretty
much I'd to get tried one with spiky
hair one with a hat woman I knew I was
gonna have the shirt bowtie invest but I
didn't know what the hair should look
like finally the slicked back seemed to
look the most I guess professional I
think it shows off my bald spots even
more but but yeah I think it seems to
wear it certainly makes him look older
which is pray the idea of the character
anyway so that's about it that never
happened